[Musique]
salam aleikoum
je pense que la jeune a tout dit
nous sommes là qu'on m'a dit nous sommes
là aujourd'hui comme al hilal ma chère
collègue professeur pour créer des
limitations dans globalement c'est
d'amener ces jeunes assorti de et à
comprendre et à comprendre que le
challenge est devant nous chaque jour
c'est une seconde chance lagence on a
reçu pour tous
une façon de
nous
chaque jour on allait souvent demandé à
nos jeunes nos enfants à 10 min on suit
n'est
malheureusement pas façon
quand même
on est quelques fois il a raison
[Musique]
en ce moment dans les maisons du parc ni
maison de l'enseignant n'est besoin d
analyse bon aloi
se retrouvèrent en surrégime et la
modélisation quelquefois en moi c'est
alice au pays des
musulmans des
campeuses ce n'est qu'en cessant de
france quelque chose non voir le second
est
déjà
l année sur la base c'est mon cher mais
les conférenciers
[Musique]
parce que photoshop chimie développement
du continent et
endogènes et
peut ne peut se construire autour des
compétences que nous
on n'en parlera plus ainsi pressenti que
c'est la colonisation c'est
moi je dis les choses à me l'a dit avec
les
doigts
je salue
ces nombres ans si nous voulons pas nous
engager
qui le sait la bonne place
voilà qui serait pleinement
des mentions dessous et je dîne j'ai
quelquefois de patience mais je continue
à voir le chapitre
la chance lui les chances du j'ai vu
c'est d'être
ski à examen je devais ensuite on
comprenait un peu autour ou
loi et du pouvoir en suisse qu'elle se
rappelle astringent et celles qui ont un
abonnement
d'acquisition
non seulement de construction
d'innovation qu'est ce que la compétence
c'est la chose qu'on est
parfois
en
itinérance
à paris deux
ans puis un chinois un jeu visant les
leaders et le leadership n'est
simplement pas soit c'est aussi des
[Musique]
grands
vaincus si vous avez un point et qu'on
ne peut pas transmettre faute à l'église
comme tel
comme moi je suis une ambiance
plus longtemps parce que
le csa
va
laisser ces militaires au
4 mai en réalité la place des vins les
six d'entre elles je suis
personnellement je vous dirais
personnellement
puis au cours dé convaincre n'a rien
ce que j'ai trouvé une souche
ça c'est une chance
vous comprenez il faut forcément pas
seulement ont reçu tous les vilains mots
tout simplement la capacité
d'innovation permanente
là je
dégage éléments contre la femme c'est
une autre
vous savez j'aime souvent compté cette
année
[Musique]
c'est une chance d'avoir connaissance
avec la chance avant les hommes
pensaient que l'afrique ait ce flou et
sujet
malheureusement tous les ans il ya eu
aussi le droit et c'est ça qui a créé
cette conclu
aujourd'hui jeudi modèles
tous les jours à 15 ans se dit que on va
être comme ça
[Musique]
le grand si elle
savait sont une chance pour l'afrique
aujourd'hui on peut penser
à
quand le projet on veut créer pascal
hier en france
mais n'ont jamais de croissance les
chiffes social innovant celui là une
chance que compte l a fait dans
simplement nouveau ressentent les
grandes vacances et se positionner des
deux appels à transférer habiter ou la
régionalisation de
selena ici que voilà deux ans qui se
voit
[Musique]
que même à l'hôpital
c'est dans ce sens
judith à l'aise
[Musique]
mais voilà l'été en faisant l'économie
du
combattant des artistes
ensuite le travail j'ai commencé
j'ai la chance de travailler avec lui
cela dit ce qui la place
dans
la chance à chaque instant à l'époque on
calculait à paris avec déroulant dans
ses sous
quels sont les coups en dessous mais un
tacle cabinet qui se
tenait dans ses mains un liquide
elle a l'opportunité
dans
une convention en disant je vous envoie
aux jeunes qu'aux
daumas
quand l'agent je trouve and so
effarement que juge alan jara grand que
non plus pas la grande rose
française
ils se parlent à l'unité la voix du nord
10 ans après
l'arrêt des pays
on se
qualifie
la crap
mois
viendra
s'il veut se reconstruire
donc voilà la réalité
et par la suite
des droits
de
[Musique]
marketing
de
la place
l'un moi je ne croyais pas
aux élèves pourquoi suis je
suis
je
et aux règles y avait cette peur mais
aussi
à l'évangile
articulations la merci je suis
très
précis
c'est une
chance
et
je continue à
les
lire
qu' aucune fiction adulte a fait
publier en juillet
ils ont
[Musique]
simplement si je crois est venu
je retrouve la jeunesse ans
et c'est comme ça que le voient déjà
pris dans
[Musique]
la seine
les entrants
sert je
sais tu joues parce qu'en fin de match
aller
2-3 shikabala
éviter ce qu'il fallait faire pour
certains c'est là où enfin
sans toutefois arrêter
là se
levant
dans
l'es6 et les actions ans mais ça s'est
construit aussi les autres références et
des
dames
[Musique]
alors
si cette relation
le tract
cette notion là il faut le gouvernement
le patronat et une aide dans vos billets
pourquoi et
comment
il est et matic une aide massive de
marché parce que je suis officiellement
mais
la menace
on a cette notion de formalités et des
enfants ravis
comprenait deux est allé voter de
transformer
la réalité dans le temps ce n'est que la
première la prédominance de travail
informel
pourquoi
et comment
tourner les formalités de sécurité
ne voit pas sympathique est nourri par
une en
vaut vraiment ce qu paradis et d'un
sonar qui sont en moi ceux conçus
je commençais à le remonter
c'est comme ça plus le jeune
letton
dans
les caisses
c'est
beaucoup plus que ce qu'ils peuvent
se
présenter le kwa
en sango ronge
et
java et je me range à
la nouvelle en finances personnelles
[Musique]
charges ou des syndicats français
j'aime retrouver une autre fois
peut-être que les familles chance me
motive parce que j'aimerais revenir au
mois
de
juin
la notion critique au niveau de
l'acquisition des compétences commencer
parfois c'est une défaillance du système
d'héritage qui joue pas son rôle
régalien et c'est à cet instant que je
me dis qu'est ce que fait danser une
peinture et crédule rejointe de créer
d'abord un bureau d'étude du guichet
social qui avait principalement objectif
de renforcer les capacités des jeunes a
h1n1
à ce qu un endroit donné on se pose la
question pourquoi est ce qu'une
entreprise doit rester avec lui d'un
célèbre gang dance si elle n'a pas vu
non plus ma
réalité
dans voilà comment au bout de quelques
années j'ai des contrats
le fond
on recevait des jeunes partie des sit-in
pour les outils n'est pas rien
même moment donné j'ai dit ça ne suffit
pas
qu'est ce que je vais faire continuer
l'institut privé université
et
je me dis d un cd rentrer dans une
dynamique de collaboration une amie de
collaboration avec
d'abord le continent africain donc là je
me situe à la coopération sud sud est
par la suite
créé ce combiné alors je lui
ai rendu les états unis plus vous voir
parce que nos enfants
nos jeunes en
[Musique]
en belles choses on n'a plus besoin
d'être situé dans une commune quel
regard vous travaillez dans 2 ce soir en
haïti
on peut franchement
dangereux s'il conclut en disant
très cher des jeux a pu nous
[Musique]
sommes
en droit
dont le challenge noire s'est
dessaisi que ce soit dans la forme a été
unanimement accepté
hier la valeur en décrue est en marche
simplement il faut chaque les salles il
s'est dit qu'est ce que on peut faire
tout semble
jouer comme lui et valdano
où vous
vous êtes c'est une chance
j'ai mes parents qui me dit quoi parce
qu'il y avait une opportunité et
nomination de quoi j'ai consulté mes
deux parents
ultime en
entrant en éruption
tiennent tout prix de la meilleure
éducation scientifique je veux célébrer
parmi les cités par une fan et collègues
pas des autres mais quand je reviens
mais mon frère
c'est parce que jeannette du taux les
gymnopédies j'attends que ça tu est un
band à lui loin que ça
dans white au même moment qui crée cette
année vernement donné jeudi béate en jeu
s'élèverait même enfer pouvoir
aux mains d'un contenu que vous lui le
challenge est admis et que chaque joute
pour donner beaucoup plus que ce que tu
as des billets et c'est un ange 10
restants de la dynamique de la
construction des de l'acquisition des
compétences en se disant nous sommes
suis un continent
et là et est rapide dans un peu ceux
conçus on peut faire des choses ou
changer la vision même du monde et
comme disait
la grande banque du monde
en temps froid on peut
[Musique]